l'alternance à matignon quelques heures
après sa victoire jacques chirac a nommé
jean pierre raffarin premier ministre il
a 53 ans il est sénateur démocratie
libérale de la vienne
peu connu du grand public et il n'a pas
fait l'ena nous retracerons en détail
son parcours et ses missions
la composition du gouvernement sera
annoncée demain il est question de
nicolas sarkozy comme numéro de ministre
de la sécurité de philippe douste-blazy
à l'éducation et de dominique de
villepin aux affaires étrangères les
résultats définitifs de l'élection
présidentielle jacques chirac
l'emportent avec 81,21 % des voix 80,2
pardon de 21% télégramme de
félicitations du monde entier le front
national lui lance sa campagne des
législatives nous irons en alsace en
bretagne dans le vaucluse est aussi
retrouvé les lycéens de toulouse et à
propos de l'extrême droite mais aux
pays-bas cette fois son chef de file pim
fortuyn qui avaient réalisé une percée
lors du dernier scrutin à rotterdam a
été la cible de tirs et lire moins de
deux heures alors qu'il entrait dans les
studios d'une radio il est entre la vie
et la mort des précisions ici la fin de
cette édition
bonsoir à tous merci de votre attention
c'est l'image du jour la passation de
pouvoirs à matignon tout à l'heure entre
lionel jospin qui a fait ses adieux on y
reviendra dans un instant et le nouveau
premier ministre nommé ce matin par
jacques chirac jean pierre raffarin il
n'est pas membre du rpr mais des
démocraties libérales
il est président de la région
poitou charentes et bénéficie d'une
image d'élu de terrain avec nicolas
sarkozy jean pierre raffarin était l'un
des favoris pour ce poste c'est donc lui
qui l'a finalement emporté
le récit de cette journée d'abord avec
laurent hakim et fabrice dujardin
toujours sénateur n'est pas encore
premier ministre pas encore matinal mais
déjà pressés à 11h ce matin jean pierre
raffarin entame son marathon émission
vous travaillez
belgique a passé la ligne donc seule
ligne samedi hier soir l'autorité
républicaine l'actionnariat et du
confort de travail sur l'avenir avec
vous à cette heure-là jean pierre
raffarin non encore à l'avant de sa
voiture son chauffeur est arrivé la
veille de poitiers la traversée de paris
va durer toute la journée
à 11h20 il est à l'elysée on a sorti les
estrades et les micros le président de
la république a nommé monsieur jean
pierre raffarin premier ministre une
heure et demie d'entretien avec jacques
chirac et quand le premier ministre
raffarin reprend sa voiture c'est
désormais pour s'asseoir à l'arrière
direction la rue de varenne histoire de
repérer l'adresse de son nouveau bureau
mais il dépasse l'hôtel matignon
car cette au sénat qu'il a rendez vous
rendez vous lui aussi pour un déjeuner
discret avec quelques élus pas très
bavard de toute façon il ya des
élections a gagné vous allez changer de
carte de visite dans les heures qui
viennent
non non non non non je reste en l'état
d'esprit de terminer mon mandat h 30 16
heures cette fois il s'arrête à matignon
la passation des pouvoirs avec le nail
jospin et expéditive
un quart d'heure plus tard le tapis
rouge et tout à lui et les photographes
aussi encore un passage à l'elysée dans
la soirée pour boucler ce marathon
politique ou automobile derrière les
grilles du palais présidentiel jean
pierre raffarin et jacques chirac met la
dernière touche à la composition du
nouveau gouvernement
alors qui est jean pierre raffarin dans
un instant nous irons dans sa ville de
poitiers
d'abord son parcours politique avec alix
bouilhaguet depuis le 9 avril dernier
c'est lui qui tenait la corde dans son
fief à poitiers au cours d'un meeting
jacques chirac le faisait monter sur
scène aux yeux de tous un signe fort
l'homme est pourtant peu connu du grand
public
ancien publicitaire animateurs des
jeunes giscardiens dans les années 70
depuis 88 il préside la région poitou
charentes à la présidentielle de 95 à la
demande de valérie giscard d'estaing il
soutient jacques chirac et peaufine son
style je suis prêt à suivre mes dossiers
je ne suis pas prêt à quitter mes
dossiers pourraient faire caler ici ou
là notamment à paris quelques jours plus
tard c'est pourtant chose faite jean
pierre raffarin devient ministre des pme
du gouvernement d'alain juppé jacques
chirac apprécié son sens de la
communication et de la formule il est
sensible à ces observations d'élu de
terrain après la dissolution manquée de
97 jean pierre raffarin va rester au
contact de jacques chirac
cet été il volera même à sa rescousse au
moment où les affaires éclaboussent le
chef de l'état quand je vois que pour
s'attaquer au président de la république
parce que c'est un homme politique fort
on va chercher des attaques sur sa
famille
quelle bassesse ces derniers mois jean
pierre raffarin était l'un des piliers
de l'union au mouvement la plaque
tournante de la campagne chiraquienne
à 53 ans l'homme n'a jamais caché qu'il
était fier d'avoir été ministre mais qui
n'y retournerai pas à n'importe quel
prix ni n'importe où et jean pierre
raffarin qui a de qui tenir puisque son
père avait été secrétaire d'état sous la
quatrième république dans le
gouvernement de pierre mendès-france
alors on l'a vu c'est pas son image
d'élu de terrain qu'il doit largement sa
réussite à poitiers dans la vienne dont
il est sénateur reportage françois
privat alain darrigrand philippe guittet
il n'était pas encore premier ministre
hier dans les rues de chasseneuil du
poitou caméras et micros suivait déjà
jean pierre raffarin de très près
raffarin l'homme de la région poitou
charentes qu'il préside depuis 1988
ici avec rené monory son maître en
politique comme lui il est très attaché
à sa terre c'est les pieds ancrés danger
dire dans la glaise du poitou il est né
d'une famille qui de rural en poitou et
donc il tient à cet ancrage territorial
et aujourd'hui il a toujours il garde
toujours cette volonté de dire je suis
dit si je suis de proches des gens pour
la république de proximité la plume d'en
bas c'est sur mac motifs champagne pour
un staff du conseil régional
poitou-charentes ses amis confirment
pour jean pierre raffarin la
convivialité ça compte
les copains d'abord en quelque sorte
lorsqu'on se retrouve entre amis comme
ça ça c'est de temps en temps
malheureusement sans doute de moins en
mois maintenant mais eh bien il refuse
que l'on se quitte avant d'avoir défini
la date de nos retrouvailles on ne se
quittent pas avant de savoir quand on se
retrouve
ça c'est très gentil raffarin et voici
jean pierre raffarin athlètes à l'âge de
16 ans ici il devance alain clayes
aujourd'hui député ps de poitiers
déjà le premier ministre figurer en tête
de liste
c'était un athlète volontaires hargneux
même en venir
et ça ça cadrait particulièrement bien
avec sa morphologie
c'était pas son style l'aider pour faire
légèreté mais c'était efficace
l'homme d'une région mais pas d'une
ville jean pierre raffarin n'a jamais
brigué la mairie de poitiers
il abandonnera ces jours ci son mandat
de sénateur de la vienne mais devrait
demeurer à la présidence de la région
poitou charentes et en plus jean pierre
raffarin serait dit on très appréciée de
bernadette chirac qui vante son humour
gérard leclerc la signification
politique de ce choix nicolas sarkozy il
incarner une droite décomplexée il était
l'autre favori pour matignon
le choix de jean pierre raffarin est
donc celui d'une autre voie nicolas
sarkozy aurait parfaitement convenu si
l'écart entre jacques chirac et jean
marie le pen avait été plus serré et
qu'il avait fallu donc mobilisés en
priorité l'électorat de droite ce n'est
pas le cas et l'a donc jean pierre
raffarin lui al'avantage d'incarner
l'ouverture promise hier par le
président élu
il n'est pas rpr mais centriste tendance
démocratie libérale dont il a rallié à
jacques chirac la plupart des
parlementaires
il symbolise aussi le renouvellement il
est peu connu des français mais c'est un
excellent communicant et puis la
décentralisation ladhuie élus de terrain
président actif de la région poitou
charentes
il représente bien c'est peu france d'en
bas qui l'opposent selon sa propre
formule à la france d'en haut
alors vous le disiez est ce un handicap
ou pas jusque là jean pierre raffarin
n'a jamais tenu les premiers rôles qui
connaît jean pierre raffarin nous avons
posé la question tout simplement dans
les rues de paris tout à l'heure loïc de
la mornais michel de bassin
mais c'est quoi mis à part il est
premier ministre messieurs
ceci dit nous attaquons mars et son nom
d'un certain hawks qui n'ont ses lots
non c'est pas lui oui enfin voilà alors
qu'il connaît qu'il connaît pas le
gagner quoi c'est pas le plus connu des
trois sites essayé comment physiquement
vous pouvez nous le décrire un petit
gros sans intérêt les dl et sa tête ne
revient pas du tout rafa rapport à
sarkozy qui me paraît beaucoup plus
prétentieux cassant
sur vos conflits carriériste je trouve
que c'est mieux
il est affable il est compétent
il en impose c'est fabuleux
c'est au sud
soit c'est quelqu'un qui est coquin
l'ancien ministre
et pme voilà la seule question que je
pose est ce qu'il a entendu les français
parce que les hommes politiques
entendent aller français le soir des
élections indoor mais oublie tout quels
qu'ils soient je ne fais pas de
politique
et puis on entre un peu dans la coulisse
de ce choix parce qu'un homme a eu une
influence déterminante c'est alain juppé
gérard oui alain juppé est plus que
jamais vraiment dans le premier cercle
des chirac elle toute la confiance du
président et on imagine facilement qu'il
a pesé de tout son poids notamment dans
le choix de jean pierre raffarin ont
parlé tout à l'heure de nicolas sarkozy
à l'évidence alain juppé préféré jean
pierre raffarin alain juppé on le sait
c'est également lui qui a accéléré les
choses pour l'union pour la majorité
présidentielle leur père était réticent
il l'a imposé notamment michèle alliot
marie
et puis quand on regarde on va en parler
tout à l'heure la composition du
gouvernement raffarin on voit qu'il ya
pas mal d'hommes qui ont sans doute été
suggéré par un gp eh bien on va examiner
cette composition même si ce
gouvernement n'est pas encore annoncée
quelques réactions d'abord bruno
gollnisch pour qui la balle est dans le
camp de jean pierre raffarin pour
conclure dit il des accords avec
l'extrême droite en vue des législatives
sinon il ne restera à son poste cinq
semaines fin de citation vincent peillon
porte parole du ps estime lui que le
gouvernement nouvellement nommé doit se
limiter à organiser le débat en vue des
législatives en attendant il n'a pas la
légitimité suffisante dit il en
substance
alors le gouvernement justement les
dernières discussions les derniers coups
de téléphone sont toujours en cours
jean-pierre raffarin a quitté l elysée
il ya quelques instants il a eu un
nouvel échange avec jacques chirac
à ce propos justement la composition de
ce gouvernement devrait être annoncé
demain matin mais quelques noms
reviennent déjà avec insistance est
d'abord celui précisément de nicolas
sarkozy pour un grand ministère de la
sécurité
on le verra dans un instant autres
promu sans doute philippe douste-blazy
lui aussi donné possible premier
ministre et qui devrait hériter sauf
surprise d'un grand ministère de
l'éducation aux compétences élargies
alix bouilhaguet philippe douste-blazy
le sourire aux lèvres
nous sommes en mars 2001 il est élu
maire de toulouse
le soir même il adresse un message à la
droite elle peut gagner
l'union à tout prix l'union même aux
dépens de sa propre famille politique
l'udf pourtant président du groupe
parlementaire de cette formation à
l'assemblée nationale il a choisi son
camp ce sera celui de jacques chirac
pendant toute la campagne philippe
douste-blazy à la cote
elle faiblira en février françois bayrou
patron de l'udf et éternel rival
détourne le rassemblement de l'union au
mouvement organisé à tous pensons tous
la même chose c'est que nous ne pensons
plus rien à 49 ans l'homme a déjà été
deux fois ministre de la santé entre 93
et 95 et de la culture entre 95 et 97
depuis il n'a jamais caché son envie de
faire à nouveau partie d'un gouvernement
autre coup de projecteur sur un homme
qui sort de l'ombre
dominique de villepin secrétaire général
de l'elysée on l'a entendu tout à
l'heure annoncé la nomination de jean
pierre raffarin est souvent présenté
comme l'éminence grise de jacques chirac
et bien il devrait diriger la diplomatie
française au ministère des affaires
étrangères donc nos routes et aux lyrics
en 1995 dominique de villepin qian ans
la composition du gouvernement est un
homme peu connu du grand public
ces annonces sont la partie visible de
sa fonction de secrétaire général de
l'elysée mais dominique de villepin dans
l'ombre est beaucoup plus il est l'homme
sur de jacques chirac voir l'éminence
grise du président énarque et ancien
diplomate dominique de villepin a été
entre 93 et 95 directeur de cabinet
d'alain juppé à l'époque ministre des
affaires étrangères l'homme que beaucoup
qualifient de flamboyant ou encore de
fougue et tout même cordialement détesté
par beaucoup de chiraquiens qu'il accuse
d'avoir été le pousse au crime de la
dissolution
à 48 ans dominique de villepin se moque
des inimitiés et considère la politique
comme une croisade il se présente
lui-même comme un spécialiste de la
gestion de crise
voilà ce sont des informations à prendre
au conditionnel philippe douste-blazy
sans doute à l'éducation dominique de
villepin sans doute aux affaires
étrangères mais la première information
à retenir sans doute c'est que la
sécurité sera bien la priorité avec un
ministère de la sécurité confié à
nicolas sarkozy qui dans l'ordre
protocolaire fera office de numéro deux
du gouvernement
laurence ostolaza précoce en politique
nicolas sarkozy se cherchent très tôt un
père spirituel
sa difficulté sera de savoir lequel élu
à 28 ans maire de neuilly sous
l'étiquette rpr il se tourne vers
jacques chirac mais c'est à edouard
balladur qu'il devra sa première
aventure ministériel mars 93 bercy en 95
il choisit son camp il soutient edouard
balladur candidat à la présidence de la
république
de lui dire que vous êtes prêts
avec lui dans le saxonin du viaur mais
c'est jacques chirac qui est élu
commence alors une traversée du désert
et ne participera pas au gouvernement
juppé 1999 échec aux élections
européennes de la liste rpr dl qu'il
conduit il assume
il renonce ensuite un autre défi
concourir à la présidence du rpr
on dit d'ailleurs en coulisses que le
président chirac lui préfère un autre
candidat
écoutez moi je suis soulagé et apaisé
j'ai pris une décision difficile ah non
non non moi je suis et travaille plutôt
du genre consciencieux exemple il garder
le contact avec les militants atr opposé
à lui m
il reste présent et se rapproche du camp
chiraquien
fin 2001 il fait campagne sur le thème
de la sécurité présente tout au long de
la campagne ces derniers mois agités
soir et moi je peux continuer dommage
qu'il humilie avril 2002 il participe à
la création de l'union pour la majorité
présidentielle
une autre politique pénale pour notre
pays
cette politique pénale doit avoir un
premier principe la tolérance zéro avril
2002 il participe à la création de l'ump
la majorité présidentielle aux côtés
d'alain juppé et il réitère la priorité
de jacques chirac
voilà nicolas sarkozy donc n'aura pas eu
matignon mais devrait hériter de ce
grand ministère de la sécurité et du
titre de numéro deux du gouvernement
confirmation donc officiel demain matin
d'autres informations sur ce qui
pourrait occuper les autres ministères
agnès molinier helen hughes deux petits
pas derrière jacques chirac se tient
alain juppé c'était il y à un mois tout
juste lors d'une réunion publique à
bordeaux l'image illustre la proximité
politique qui a toujours existé entre
les deux hommes ce soir là les militants
et des soucis parce que là pour
l'instant rendez sur alain juppé qui ne
sera pas lue au gouvernement il annoncé
depuis longtemps et vous nous le
confirment y est gérard il ya un instant
en revanche on a des indications des
informations qui circulent avec
insistance depuis ce matin sur les
autres noms pour les autres ministères
nous sommes maintenant en mesure de
vous en donner connaissance avec donc
agnès molinier une femme à la défense
une première michèle alliot-marie
présidente du rpr depuis l'automne 99
pourrait obtenir ce portefeuille rpr lui
aussi dominique perben pourrait se voir
confier la justice ce proche de jean
pierre raffarin a déjà été ministre des
dom-tom et de la fonction publique
pourrait être confié à un médecin proche
de jean claude gaudin jean françois
mattei initiateur des lois sur la
bioéthique
il est président du groupe démocratie
libérale à l'assemblée des ministères
sont en balance les affaires sociales
peut-être pour françois fillion ex
compagnon de route de philippe séguin
il a déjà été ministre de la recherche
puis de la faust à moins qu'il
n'obtienne l'équipement portefeuille
pour lequel est également pressenti
gilles de robien député maire udf damien
autres udf jean louis borloo député
maire de valenciennes qui a fait venir
toyota dans sa commune il pourrait se
voir confier le poste de ministre de la
ville pour les affaires européennes
l'ancienne présidente du parlement de
strasbourg
nicole fontaine aurait la préférence la
culture reviendrait au président du
centre beaubourg
jean jacques aillagon c'est l'homme qui
a préparé des festivités du passage à
l'an 2000 enfin à la jeunesse et aux
sports
un marseillais renaud muselier premier
adjoint de la cité phocéenne
ce serait pour lui un beau cadeau il a
43 ans aujourd'hui mais on en est
toujours cause hypothèse rappelons le
alors jacques chirac hier avait parlé d'
un gouvernement de mission gérard
leclerc commentaire sur cet écrit côté
on peut dire c'est à la fois un
gouvernement resserré politique et de
combat électoral resserré une quinzaine
de ministres seulement les ministres
délégués secrétaire d'état avec
davantage sans doute de jeunes devrait
être nommée après les législatives c'est
un gouvernement très politique avec les
poids lourds de l'actuelle opposition
comme nicolas sarkozy ou philippe
douste-blazy plusieurs était déjà
ministre sous alain juppé on le dit
c'est pas forcément un hasard par
exemple françois fillon et dominique
perben
d'autres sont deux fortes personnalités
comme dominique de villepin et puis il
devrait y avoir comme toujours la
surprise là où les surprises peut-être
le pdg francis mer enfin c'est un
gouvernement de combat électoral de
mission d et jacques chirac pour
s'engager tout de suite dans l'ex
avec des mesures d'urgence ou des
annonces fortes sur la sécurité la
baisse des impôts et des charges et le
dialogue social par exemple le conflit
et fait des médecins le tout on l'a
compris avec toujours en ligne de mire
les élections législatives merci gérard
cette journée était donc celle de la
consécration pour jean pierre raffarin
elle restera aussi celle des adieux de
lionel jospin
ovationné à son départ de matignon
jacques villain vers matignon elysées ce
trajet là lionel jospin lors accompli au
moins une fois chaque semaine pendant
cinq ans aujourd'hui c'est la dernière
encore premier ministre pour quelques
instants il est accueilli sur les
marches de l'elysée par le secrétaire
général dominique de villepin
mais un quart d'heure plus tard les
formalités ont été brèves
c'est le chef de l'état en personne
comme le veut la tradition républicaine
qui raccompagne lionel jospin
la cohabitation s'achèvera sur cette
image à matignon pendant ce temps c'est
une autre cérémonie qui se prépare la
passation des pouvoirs
côté photographes et caméras l'affluence
des très grands jours côté public le
personnel de matignon tout entier dans
les rangs serrés beaucoup de roses
rouges
16 heures lionel jospin accueille son
successeur et il l'appelle d'emblée par
son nouveau titre
tout ira là aussi très vite moins de 20
minutes se sont écoulées lorsque lionel
jospin quitte définitivement matignon
sous les applaudissements
à ce moment beaucoup ont du mal à
retenir leur émotion passé beaucoup de
temps à ses côtés est impossible je
pense que le premier ministre était
aussi quelqu'un de bien et puis je pense
que les français le regretteront quant à
ses plus proches conseillers ils ont
paraît-il quitté ans lionel jospin sera
ça n'était certainement pas une posture
c'est quelque chose qu'on a ressenti
profondément et qui je crois nous a tous
fait du bien corps dans des tapis rouges
sont remisés
la cérémonie s'achève un nouveau
locataire s'est installé à matignon et
dernier geste de lionel jospin il a
reversé au trésor public près de 3
millions d'euros un peu moins de 20
millions de francs de fonds spéciaux non
utilisés conformément aux engagements
pris en juillet dernier lionel jospin
qui avait fait ses cartons la semaine
dernière déjà la déménagement également
pour ses ministres exemple avec marylise
lebranchu une équipe de complément
d'enquêté emmené par audrey gloaguen
était à ses côtés le rangement et les
adieux au ministère de la justice
témoignage encore
jamais autant de coups de fil et
messages depuis que quand j'ai vu le
visage du nouveau président est dit que
c'était quand même injuste
voilà donc fiers de la gauche c est
triste à la fois parce que il s'est
passé quelque chose que j'avale pas bien
bon va falloir préparer les quelques
fiches pour pour le suivant sur les
dossiers tout est propre tout est
l'étendard et toutes époques
il faut qu'on se trouver un endroit un
bios à paris pire le web demain ça ne
deviendra pas de retrouver un bureau
ordinaire non un bureau normale n'était
pas mal
j'ai perdu
enfin en faire pousser un peu par 20 ça
peut pas rentrer
c est un ministère qu'elle moi j'aurais
eu en tout cas beaucoup de plaisir à
travailler je me disais que le dommage
c'est ce soit si court
j'ai l'impression d'être arrivé à peu de
temps quand on parle beaucoup plus des
as sécurité que de la démocratie ces
milices à la justice qui est le dernier
bastion de résistance porté très loin
les valeurs de la république et des
libertés
vous avez vraiment là un privilège c'est
travailler ici alors bravo à vous les
privilégiés
marylise lebranchu aujourd'hui on verra
tout à l'heure un autre extrait de ce
magazine complément d'enquêté juste
après le journal
à noter que les négociations entre ps et
pc sur d'éventuelles candidatures
uniques dans les circonscriptions
difficile aux législatives piétine le pc
dénoncer tout à l'heure je cite l'esprit
hégémonique du ps on revient maintenant
sur la victoire de jacques chirac hier
soir avec d'abord les résultats
définitifs 80 2,21 pour le président
réélu 17,79 pour jean marie le pen
résultats très proches des estimations
que nous vous donnions hier soir dès 20h
chiffres définitifs de l'abstention
aussi 20,29 % des électeurs inscrits une
soirée de triomphe donc et des accents
gaulliens pour jacques chirac l'a fait
pour ses partisans retour sur les temps
forts alexandre kara jean yves blanc un
simple chiffre et c'est la joie comme un
grand soulagement qui envahit la
bastille communiste lcr verts de gauche
d'ailleurs ils sont des milliers à se
lancer dans une fête improvisée
à quelques boulevards de la une
marseillaise pour le vainqueur aux
balcons line renaud henri salvador et
enfin le couple présidentiel
comme il ya sept ans les rues de paris
défilent la voiture a changé le scénario
lui a des allures de déjà vu à la
république la souris s'organise plus de
dix mille personnes attendent leurs
héros pour rendre hommage à cette france
qui lui a donné la victoire le président
réélu a des accents gaulliens j'ai
entendu et j'ai compris ce que les
françaises et les français on dit il est
temps de retrouver le sens de l'action
au service de chaque française et de
chaque français dans la foule c'est un
esprit joyeux black blanc beur diront
certains pas toujours chiraquien mais
passionnément républicain tout paris
cosmo colis est réunie derrière la
victoire de jacques chirac où les
valeurs de la république on attend qu'on
a commercial et au sacro-saint que jean
marie le pen ne peut pas être
résidant au caire en france il ya des
gens qui sont un tir en sommeil des
démocraties
pendant ce temps rive gauche à l'appel
de la ligue communiste révolutionnaire
une manifestation s'improvise ici pas
question d'oublier que le vote chirac a
d'abord été un vote contre le pen est
nul en trois ans pour s'être investi la
fête se poursuit et déjà on s'interroge
sur l'avenir
place de la république ni le froid ni la
pluie ne gâche la fête
on voudrait chanter danser jusqu'au bout
de la nuit pour oublier ces quinze jours
qui ont ébranlé le paysage politique
français et plus de 25 millions de
français ont donc voté pour le chef de
l'état c'est évidemment du jamais vu
rappelons nous qu il y a quelques
semaines encore on disait le président
candidat fragilisé par la cohabitation
par les affaires par un septennat
marquée par une dissolution
catastrophique
une fois de plus jacques chirac a donc
rebondi on s'arrête un moment sur ce
destin politique entre chute et
résurrection recife les boiseries josé
boulesteix c'était en 1974 et le premier
ministre jacques chirac se gardait bien
de jouer les visionnaires fonds ans plus
tard son itinéraire politique mais que
virage accident débâcle revenge et
résurrection
une enfance corrézienne une adolescence
turbulente avant de se retrouver sur la
voie royale
lennar un beau mariage et un premier
mandat de député en 1967 en corrèze
bien sûr garde ses premiers pas
ministériels sous les ailes protectrices
de georges pompidou le laisse orphelins
en 1974 dans l'élection présidentielle
qui suit il abandonne le candidat de son
parti jacques chaban delmas pour le camp
du vainqueur
valéry giscard d'estaing la douze
premiers ministres deux ans juste le
temps d'apprendre à se détester
je ne dispose pas des moyens que
j'estime aujourd'hui nécessaire pour
assumer efficacement mes fonctions le
premier ministre jacques chirac invente
alors une arme redoutable le rpr le
costume est encore un peu court tout
comme en 80 pour sa première campagne
présidentielle 18% au premier tour
l'important c'est la foi la foi dans le
progrès la foi dans la justice la fois
dans la grandeur de la france
sa foi va pourtant être mise à rude
épreuve en 86 2 ans de cohabitation avec
françois mitterrand qui les rentes
pouvez-vous vraiment contester ma
version des choses en me regardant dans
les yeux dans les yeux je la conteste sa
deuxième tentative à l'élection
présidentielle de 88 se termine en
camoufler il pense à ce moment là
abandonné la vie politique
ils m'en parlent plusieurs fois il me
dit finalement il dit presque j'ai tout
raté et l'homme repart malgré tout il a
appris à se méfier de la cohabitation
mais pas de ses amis en 93
il laisse edouard balladur à matignon
gérer les affaires sans voir qu'il se
crée un adversaire
voilà l'homme embourbé en pleine
campagne des amis se font rares
même lui a du mal à croire à sa destinée
on n'a pas gagné le 7 mai 95 à sa
troisième tentative jacques chirac voit
enfin s'ouvrir les portes de l'elysée
le voilà au firmament pour deux ans pour
cause de gouvernement juppé chahuté par
la rue jacques chirac optent pour la
dissolution
il gagne une nouvelle cohabitation mais
l'adversité l'huissier les juges ont
ball attaqué de toutes parts lionel
jospin a beau garder une cote de
confiance inégalé après cinq ans à
matignon
rien n'y fait l'histoire voudra même que
jacques chirac soit plébiscitée il
retrouve le firmament sans savoir
vraiment de quoi demain sera fait alors
un coup d'oeil sur la carte électorale
et les départements où l'on a le plus
voté pour jacques chirac ce sont les
dom-tom + 2 96% par exemple en
martinique qu'en métropole record est
détenu par la corrèze plus de 90%
d'une manière générale vous le voyez
c'est l'ouest et le sud-ouest qui ont le
plus accorder leur suffrage la bretagne
notamment
reportage jacques devaux michel hilaire
saint nazaire depuis 75 ans la ville n'a
connu que trois maires tous de gauche
dans cette cité ouvrière l'extrême
gauche a réalisé près de 15% au premier
tour
et pourtant jacques chirac a recueilli
90 % des suffrages
ce soit les verts où la gauche tout le
monde a appelé à voter pour chirac c'est
bien normal quand on voit le côté c'est
la haine c'est tout le choix il est déjà
fait pour beaucoup d'ouvriers voter
chirac n'était pas évident il n'y a
pourtant pas eu de défection
le programme économique de le pen n'y
est peut-être pas étranger faut savoir
que ont travaillé que deux paquebots à l
étranger et si demain on pas mais
frontières les bacs bosque ont peut-être
plus là et donc à plus de boulot
est ce dangereux pour tout le monde à
rennes non plus la population n'a pas eu
d'états d'âme trois députés un maire
socialiste mais cependant jacques chirac
a recueilli 92 % des voix mais dans
cette ville universitaire et
administratives
l'extrême gauche n'a jamais dépassé 8%
c'est aussi une des villes les moins
extrémistes en france donc il ya je
pense quasiment tous les démocrates qui
ont voté pour lui hier soir du finistère
à la loire atlantique partout les mêmes
scores autour de 90% pour jacques chirac
niveau scolaire élevé développement
économique immigration faible dans
l'ouest l'extrême droite n'a jamais fait
recette
alors le vote justement pour jean marie
le pen maintenant avec d'abord une
précision puisque nous en parlions hier
soir déjà
si l'on additionne les voix de bruno
mégret de jean-marie le pen au premier
tour il ya quinze jours on s'aperçoit
que le président du front national a
gagné des voix par rapport au total de
l'extrême droite mais en nombre réduit
loin de 54 mille voix de gains entre les
deux tours pour le front national réuni
en bureau politique aujourd'hui il
s'agit néanmoins d'une performance
retour sur ces dernières 24 heures avec
arnaud boutet et fanny au dernier
18 % quand même c'est quand même pas mal
au front national
certains ne s'avouent pas vaincus au
risque de paraître ridicule mais c'est
vraiment une grande victoire 18 % en
revanche d'autres ne digèrent pas le
résultat d'hier et s'enflamme rapidement
on n'a pas fait campagne d'information
là on a près de la désinformation
cabaye s'en retourner dans sa tombe jean
marie le pen lui ne veut pas perdre de
temps dès cet après midi il a convoqué
un bureau politique pour aborder la
prochaine échéance
comment s'annonce et n'hésite hâtive ont
gagné un million deux mois entre 720
mille exactement dont celle de bruno
mégret
aux législatives le fn espère atteindre
le second tour dans plusieurs dizaines
de circonscriptions
il veut jouer les arbitres et réclament
sans trop y croire
une part de proportionnelle dans le mode
de scrutin
hier soir à 20 heures voilà ce que l'on
pouvait entendre devant le siège du fn
la consigne était claire pas de contact
avec les militants
quelques minutes plus tard lors de la
sortie l'écrit manque un peu de
spontanéité au front national
les premiers déçus s'expriment à qui on
a mené une telle espérance et bien ils
vont voir ce qui va se passer dans les
années qui vont venir
leur situation est très divisée dans le
camp des perdants c'est enfin la fête et
jean marie le pen confirme qu'il ne sera
pas candidat aux législatives mais il
vient encourager ses troupes abandonné
jamais le combat ce combat quelques
militants veulent le mener aussi avec
bruno mégret
on représente comme 20 % 20 % des
lecteurs de l'électorat c'est quand même
pas négligeable faire taire les
querelles quoi ah oui absolument je
pense oui hein
hier soir à saint cloud les jeunes du
mouvement ont beaucoup dansé chanté même
si pour certains le moral n'était pas à
la fête
le front national vient de prouver qu'il
n'est plus marginal la chenille
frontiste veut maintenant poursuivre son
chemin la carte du vote front national
comme au premier tour elle dessine un
arc qui couvre l'est du pays
les meilleurs scores sont enregistrés
dans la région provence alpes côte
d'azur plus de 27% dans les bouches du
rhône plus de 28% dans le var les alpes
maritimes et 29,6 pour cent dans le
vaucluse
exemple à cavaillon jean marie le pen a
réuni sur son nom près de 35% des voix
dans la ville yannick à rossi de nos
jours dans sur place la nouvelle s'est
certainement déplacer à la vitesse du
tam tam
pourtant elle ne semble pas troubler la
quiétude de cavaillon ici jean marie le
pen a réalisé hier l'un de ces scores
les plus importants 34,77 % des
suffrages
si les gens sont contents n'y a pas de
raison
que ça soit pas bien ça me fait plaisir
quand tout le monde est content pourquoi
les cavaillonnais votre le ps je
comprends pas votre cavaillon 25000
habitants une cité hlm ne défraie pas
vraiment la chronique sécuritaire
quelques voitures brûlées à noël 2001
des actes d'incivilité c'est ce que met
en avant les électeurs de le pen pour le
maire les raisons de la crise sont
essentiellement économiques la capitale
du melon autrefois riche cité agricole a
perdu de son lustre
aujourd'hui c'est une ville où il ya
beaucoup de logements sociaux
beaucoup de difficultés ou et là des
futurs larivot pu allier de vous donc
c'est une ville aux difficultés et un
vote contestataire qui progresse
pourtant ici pas de permanence du front
national et les deux conseillers
municipaux d'extrême droite sont
mégrétistes extrémistes centre de ces
emprises en cavaillon c'est justement on
pas le moment de baisser les bras c'est
le moment au contraire de le crier haut
et fort ce que qu'on en veut pas de ces
attaques s'inscrivent la campagne des
législatives vient de démarrer
en 1997 le maintien de la candidate du
fn au deuxième tour avait facilité la
victoire de la gauche dans une
triangulaire en alsace en revanche jean
marie le pen a reculé entre les deux
tours en pourcentage reportage à
mulhausen commune de 380 habitants au
pied des vosges où il est passé de 37 à
28 % des voix
christophe médard sylvain gauthier
à mulhausen la nouvelle a vite fait le
tour pour la première fois le vote
d'extrême droite a reculé dans le
village
- 9 % par rapport au premier tour de
quoi satisfaire tous ceux qui ont fait
barrage à jean marie le pen
j'ai bien pour le village doit il est
pas passé c'est chiant fut la joie mais
bon c'est encore trop on a encore du
travail à faire je pense dans ce village
la mobilisation anti le pen a donc payé
le pasteur de la commune s'est beaucoup
engagée pour responsabiliser ses
concitoyens aujourd'hui il a
l'impression que son message a été
entendu
nous avons dit et redit dans cette
région à la foi chrétienne est
importante
l'incompatibilité entre les idées
extrémistes et l'évangile donc ça a
servi mais d'un autre côté il ne faut
pas oublier que ce vote a révélé aussi
la base de vos d'adhésion qui existe qui
est forte dans notre région comme
ailleurs
car l'extrême droite même si le recul
reste bien implantée dans ce canton
hier un quart des électeurs à donner sa
voix à jean marie le pen
parmi eux beaucoup de jeunes au discours
dénué de toute ambiguïté le pen pour que
la france arrête france parce qu'il
s'est fait attendre cailloux arino
jean-françois sera immigrés dans notre
pays
reste que depuis hier laisse n'est plus
montrés du doigt il ya trente ans encore
elle figurait en tête du vote d'extrême
droite aux présidentielles
elle se place désormais derrière quatre
autres régions mais beaucoup de
spécialistes du vote souligné dès hier
soir que la mobilisation avait profité à
jacques chirac
grâce en partie aux manifestations
organisées depuis une quinzaine de jours
alors comment a t'on accueilli ces
résultats chez les lycéens concernés
exemple à toulouse reportage isabelle de
lyon david bres sortie du lycée saint
sernin dans le centre de toulouse
beaucoup de jeunes partent et 10,6 pour
manifester aujourd'hui il s'est dit
soulagé ou ainsi mobilisé sa servi à
quelque chose c'est bien mais au moins
on sait réagir quand il le faut montrer
que la france n'était pas un pays
fasciste
chacun s'est remise au travail objectif
baccalauréat
mais en arrière-plan les législatives
vont maintenant c'est vrai que rien
n'est gagné quoi il faut vraiment que le
pen place au monde soit possible
législatifs et ça occupe encore les
esprits les propos sont moins virulents
mais il ya encore des inquiétudes oui
tout à fait les lycées ont retrouvé leur
calme à l'université du mirail une
assemblée générale ne fait pas le plein
certains étudiants ont voté à
contrecoeur d'autres se sont abstenus
ils avertissent chirac on n'est pas du
qu'il est passé au premier tour il est
quand même le signe qui a une crosse
rupture et que les gens se posent
beaucoup de questions qu'il ya beaucoup
de problèmes sociaux
mon avis c'est pas chirac qui va y
répondre c'est pas non plus chirac qui
pose des questions donc là il faut
continuer à organiser des forums et ça
nous de lancer c'est des malades
auparavant il jouer sur la peur des
arabes avec le beau discours du bruit
l'odeur maintenant ils jouent sur la
peur du fn
c'est une très belle manoeuvre politique
et c'est lui la critique toute politique
sécuritaire à venir dans cet amphi il a
du succès
et puis nous avons également suivi la
soirée électorale auprès d'une famille
d'origine marocaine installée en france
depuis près de trente ans on se
souviendra longtemps des deux semaines
qui viennent de s'achever reportage à
ablon sur seine près de paris gilles
marinais nabila laïb anne-laure mérignac
épilogue d'un après-midi interminables
autour du thé la famille quelques amis
et beaucoup d'anxiété
le nom du futur président il sans doute
mais quel sera le support 82,4 en bourse
ça fait plaisir de j'étais déçu j'ai
l'espoir
les enfants de richard ont la
nationalité française pas aide à défaut
de pouvoir voter la partager
l'angoissent de cette journée
particulière
les premiers tours as my son ami
sandrine n'ont pas voté contrairement
aux garçons
elle était en vacances ils pensaient
qu'après tout la politique pouvait se
passer d'elle changement de ton la
démocratie c'est quelque chose d'acquis
alors en fait justement ça nous a permis
de saluer çà pouvait très bien se
renverser faut aller voter à chaque oeil
sans quoi il parle puisque je vous savez
un petit peu parce que si ce serait
vêtue pour une élection ça sert à rien
on poste qui m'intéresse at-il fait
triangulaire est bon à le pen y aura
beaucoup plus de deux députés à
l'assemblée nationale et donc forcément
à la fois au niveau des lois et tous
quelques heures plus tôt zakaria et
karim parcours est encore li cité pour
persuader leurs amis d'aller voter dans
leur ville l'abstention a reculé de 10%
ils peuvent se dire qu'ils y sont pour
quelque chose
et une dernière image à propos du vote
front national c'est une scène un
dialogue il a été saisi hier en milieu
d'après midi donc juste avant les
premières indications sur le vote entre
jean marie le pen et bruno gollnisch
c'est l'une des séquences que vous
découvrirez juste après ce journal dans
un complément d'enquêté
exceptionnel extraits tout est prêt à
jeter tout en précisant que ce sont ce
qui manque encore c'est de savoir
quelles seraient les aliments du tunnel
à l'effort de la saône et autant que
mieux vaut mieux pour utiliser les
nôtres oui mais c'est plus d'à côté fait
plus chier et des coutumes des gens je
vous créiez des gentianes auront quand
même dire que j'y trouve extraordinaire
c'est celle aux pattes non non je dirais
que vous avez salué le geste de vienne
jospin ya quinze jours et est ce que ça
veut dire que si vous n'êtes pas élu ce
soir peut-être vous retiré david quinn
non non non je ne tue pas je suis bon
soir benoît duquesne vous êtes henric de
l'assemblée nationale d'où vous
présenterez ce magazine spécial ce soir
vous étiez dans la coulisse avec vos
équipes
vous avez je crois a suivi quatre
proches des candidats
oui absolument d'abord un mot sur cette
assemblée puisque nous sommes là bien
sûr pour une des questions qui se posent
maintenant vous en avez parlé dans le
journal c'est de savoir de quelle
couleur sera cette assemblée d'ici
maintenant un mois effectivement nous
avons pendant tous les quinze jours de
l'entre-deux-tours pu suivre un certain
nombre de personnalités qu'il s'agisse
de bruno gollnisch convient de voir de
nicolas sarkozy de martine aubry ou
encore de jean glavany nous avons nous
les avons suivis mais nous avons suivi
aussi un certain nombre de militants de
base de terrain que ce soit des
militants du front national à 11,1 dans
le nord du rpr à lyon ou encore des anti
front national du côté de marseille
autant de regards croisés sur cette
france qui bouge qui se mobilisent
qu'ils redécouvrent brutalement la
politique et nous parlerons de et vient
de tout ces événements là à notre à
travers le film mais aussi à travers ses
invités ses militants qui seront sur le
plateau avec nous ce soir
merci benoît et à tout à l'heure donc
pour une émission en direct
les législatives précisément et bien
premier tour dans cinq semaines avec une
grande inconnue
les candidats du front national
peuvent-ils être présents en grand
nombre au second tour lors de duels ou
de triangulaire et donc jouer les
arbitres rappelons qu il suffit
d'obtenir 12,5 pour cent des inscrits
pour se maintenir au second tour et sur
la base des scores du premier tour de la
présidentielle ce serait le cas pour le
fn dans plus de 230 circonscriptions sur
un calcul bien sûr sans doute un peu
simpliste mais qui inquiète à gauche et
à droite nathalie moisan gaël chauvin
1er mai 97 le front national se voit
déjà à l'assemblée jean marie le pen
présente ses 577 candidats
le leader du front lui n'ira pas à la
bataille cinq ans après il renonce de
nouveau à se présenter
mais ces ambitions sont intactes fort du
résultat du premier tour de la
présidentielle dans l'est et le sud de
la france
le front national ambitionne d'être
présent en juin dans 230 cette
circonscription second tour avec 12 et
demi pour cent le candidat frontiste
peut en effet se maintenir
le risque le plus important c'est
d'empêcher l'élection d'un candidat de
la droite démocratique
avec pour conséquence si le ce a se
multiplient d'empêcher la voie
démocratique d'avoir une majorité
parlementaire
et c'est que ça permettrait à la gauche
démocratique d'arriver au pouvoir alors
qu'elle ne serait pas majoritaire
puisque électoralement le pays est à
droite
en 97 au second tour ils y avaient tué
76 triangulaire la gauche l'avait
emporté 47 fois la droite
29 des candidats frontistes un seul
était élu jean-marie le chevallier à
tous non élection invalidée par la suite
pour éviter en juin une vague d'extrême
droite à l'assemblée le parti socialiste
prépare déjà des accords à gauche
ce que nous avons souhaité ce que
souhaite aussi nos différents
partenaires
c'est que des candidatures uniques et de
rassemblement n'est pas la même chose
puisse se mettre en place partout où il
y à un danger même
de rassemblement à droite où l'on
prépare des candidatures uniques sous la
bannière de l'union pour la majorité
présidentielle
le futur parti chiraquien on termine ce
long chapitre politique avec les
réactions à l'étranger puisque la
présence de jean marie le pen avait fait
la une de très nombreux journaux en
europe et dans le monde
réaction rassemblés par paul de genève
plébiscite pour chirac titrait ce matin
la repubblica ironisant sur le score du
président qui fera même pas lire
napoléon
la presse italienne est unanime elle
salue la victoire de jacques chirac mais
reste prudente quant à l'issue des
législatives
et pour le chef du gouvernement silvio
berlusconi c'est son cher ami chirac qui
a triomphé
une satisfaction partagée ce matin par
le numéro deux du gouvernement italien
la france a démontré qu aimer voulait
pas une adventures une mauvaise aventure
et je suis satisfait surtout pour
dans la presse britannique
les journalistes ont poussé un soupir de
soulagement le premier ministre tony
blair lui a qualifié la réélection de
jacques chirac de victoire pour la
démocratie et deux défaites pour
l'extrémisme et la politique répugnante
de le pen en allemagne aussi la large
victoire de jacques chirac est vécue
comme un rejet de l'extrémisme la
république française a clairement rejeté
la xénophobie et l'extrême droite
c'est très important pour l'europe et ça
dépasse largement les frontières de la
france
une réaction partagée d hier soir et ce
matin par l'ensemble des partenaires
européens la france a montré qu'elle
était au coeur de l'europe a résumé le
président de la commission européenne
romano prodi
mais la réaction la plus rapide est
venue de washington dc hier soir avant
même la fin du scrutin le secrétaire
d'état colin powell s'était félicité à
la télévision que jean marie le pen soit
marginalisée de façon aussi écrasant
l'extrême droite encore mais aux pays
bas je vous le disais dans les titres
sont chefs de file pub fortune dont on
prédisait une percée aux législatives a
été victime d'un attentat
un inconnu lui a tiré dessus à l'entrée
des studios de la radio publique
néerlandaise
le gouvernement vient de confirmer sa
mort anne consignes et dans l'ambulance
qui le transporte à l'hôpital pims
fortin est entre la vie et la mort
grièvement touché par six balles alors
qu'il sortait d'un studio radio une
fortune était en pleine campagne
électorale une campagne qu'il menait
deux studios radio en plateau télé car
sa toute jeune formation politique
n'avait pas les moyens d'organiser de
grands meetings le voit s'il y a
quelques jours filmé par la presse
internationale qui s'arrachait ses
interviews car l'homme est un phénomène
politique ancien universitaire
homosexuel déclaré
il a raflé 30% des suffrages aux
municipales de rotterdam ses positions
anti-immigration le faut comparer à jean
marie le pen mais lui refuse la
référence au front national
je suis atterré par l'antisémitisme de
jean-marie le pen
c'est un homme qui dit que le low cost
est un détail de l'histoire ça je ne
peux pas le cas de rendre
une forte a récusé les accusations de
racisme mais qualifié la culture
musulmane d'arriérés mes propos qui
briser des tabous dans la très tolérante
société néerlandaise une forte à n'était
créditée de 15% d'intentions de vote aux
élections générales du 15 mai proche il
circulait sans protection particulière
comme le montre cette scène filmée
vendredi dernier alors qu'il parle à la
presse un homme le prend à partie dans
la rue cette fois là c'était amical dans
la confirmation du gouvernement
néerlandais pendant ce journal pim
fortune est mort une réaction en france
celle de bruno mégret président du mnr
qui se dit profondément choqué la
réaction du front national aussi nous
nous entretenions aucun rapport avec son
parti dit on au fn on ne peut que
s'incliner devant la mort de quelqu'un
mais nous ne savons pas s'il s'agit d'un
assassinat politique ou du à ses moeurs
réaction du front national on aura bien
sûr l'occasion d'en reparler dès demain
en allemagne la première grande grève
depuis sept ans suivi très près partout
en europe et notamment en france grèves
tournantes des métallos à l'appel du
puissant syndicat ig metall au centre du
mouvement les salaires patrice romedenne
sur place à dernier le danger pour la
manière c'est que la chine finisse par
réunir 3 millions de personnes 3
millions c'est à peu près le nombre
d'adhérents du syndicat ig metall qui
promet une grève dure sachs comme un
film 6,5 pour cent d'augmentation de
salaire soit le double de ce qu'on leur
propose
c'est ce que réclament les grévistes qui
dénonce l'érosion de leur pouvoir
d'achat
cependant que les actionnaires
encaissent des dividendes les six élus
pour cent bien sûr qu'on les obtiendra
pas porsche mercedes audi pour l'heure
le mouvement s'exprime dans les usines
qui symbolise le luxe allemand le
patronat lui est d'autant moins enclins
à céder qu'il bénéficie de l'appui du
gouvernement qui prône lui aussi la
modération salariale
mais de cela les syndicats refusent
d'entendre parler ils se défendent de
faire de la politique
nous faisons la grève ni contre gerhard
schröder ni contre qui que ce soit
d'autre
nous faisons la grève pour obtenir un
résultat il nous irons jusqu'au bout
cette grève n'est certes pas dirigée
contre gerhard schröder mais il est
évident que le chancelier s'en serait
volontiers passé un peu moins de cinq
mois d'élections législatives dont il
n'est pas le favori
en bref toujours à l'étranger marc
ravalomanane officiellement investi
président à madagascar devant plus de
cent mille personnes
son rival le président sortant didier
ratsiraka dénonce un coup d'état à son
camp a proclamé depuis quelques jours
l'indépendance de quatre des six
provinces du pays
en birmanie la liberté après 19 mois de
résidence surveillée pour aung san suu
kyi la junte au pouvoir promet à cette
occasion une nouvelle page pour le pays
le prix nobel de la paix elle a appelé
immédiatement à lutter pour la
démocratie ce maryse burgot elle
représente leur seul espoir de vivre un
jour en démocratie
elle vient de vivre pendant plus d'un an
et demi coupés du reste du monde
assigné à résidence dans sa maison de
rangoun alors ce matin autour de sa
frêle silhouette
c'est un peu les mains en sang soo çi
visage toujours aussi serein mais
obstiné vient d'être libéré infatigable
combattante ses premiers mots concerne
ses compatriotes privée de liberté
moi et mon parti sommes très déçus que
c'est que de prisonniers politiques
était libéré
nous espérons que les obstacles à leur
libération seront levés très vite parce
que c'est important du point de vue
humanitaire mais aussi politique plus
populaire que jamais en dessous de ce
qui est en train de devenir une
véritable légende en 1990 cette femme et
son parti remporte les élections
législatives en birmanie
les militaires refusent de lui remettre
le pouvoir c'est le début d'un long
combat
nous l'avions rencontré il ya deux ans
au siège de son parti
elle s'apprêtait alors à engager un
nouveau bras de fer avec les généraux
cette image de sa voiture bloquée sur un
pont et désormais célèbre aung san suu
kyi voulait aller visiter ses partisans
en province
refus catégorique des militaires depuis
ce matin cette femme est donc à nouveau
libre de ses mouvements mais le plus dur
reste à faire engager de véritables
pourparlers politiques avec la junte
en bref en algérie 15 militaires tués
hier près de tizi ouzou en kabylie dans
une embuscade tendue par un groupe
islamiste armé les assaillants
appartiendrait au groupe salafiste pour
la prédication et le combat d'hassan
hattab selon la presse algérienne
retour en france avec cet attentat
manqué contre la caserne de reuilly dans
le 12e arrondissement de paris une
charge de 2 kg d'explosifs a été
découverte ce matin dans la cour le
c'était en cours la police n'écarte pas
la piste corse piste corse également
évoqué à marseille où un hôtel des
impôts a été pris pour cible et
gravement endommagé par une explosion à
paris toujours encore une annulation
d'un d'une épreuve d'un concours
d'enseignants l'épreuve du capes de
lettres modernes
motif le vol d'un lot de 86 copies
les 5000 330 candidats devront
recomposer le 1er juin prochain
justice l'audition aujourd'hui de robert
pirès l'international français a été
entendu cet après midi à marseille dans
le cadre d'une enquête ouverte sur les
comptes de l'olympique de marseille et
les transferts il était notamment
interrogé sur les conditions de son
transfert de metz à marseille en 98 puis
de l'om à arsenal en juillet 2007
dernières nouvelles enfin à propos de
marseille l'organigramme de l'om
continue à se mettre en place pour la
saison prochaine on a appris aujourd'hui
la nomination d'alain perrin comme
manager général
il était jusque là entraîneur du club
2/3 du football encore avec cette image
de la joie des joueurs de l'olympique
lyonnais de leurs supporters défilé cet
après-midi dans les rues de la ville
pour fêter le premier titre de champion
france de l'histoire du club après la
victoire face à lens 3 buts à 1 samedi
dernier fin de cette édition à suivre la
météo nathalie rihouet puis le point
route de valérie maurice l'info sur
france 2 donc dans une dizaine de
minutes complément d'enquêté spéciale
benoît duquesne en direct de l'assemblée
nationale la france dans la
présidentielle une heure le journal de
la nuit jean claude renaud on se quitte
sur ces images de bruno peyron et son
équipage nouveau détenteur depuis
dimanche du trophée jules
harnes 64 jours pour le tour du monde
chaude ambiance hier soir à brest pour
accueillir les héros bruno véron qui
rêvent déjà d'un tour du monde en moins
de 60 jours
à demain complément enquête benoît
duquesne dans un instant
à